hey guys in this video I want to share
with you an amazing recipe we're gonna
make what are we gonna make
we're gonna make peanut butter cups
peanut butter cups you know Bunny cups
peanut butter cups okay let's show you
how
so the peanut butter cups have been in
the freezer for about 15 minutes 20
minutes max and I use these molds there
they pop out really easy just turn
upside down and pop them out obviously
we can pop them all out but right now
just going to show you one perfect
peanut butter cup cut it so you can see
the center it looks like a real peanut
butter cup peanut Bunny yes I see if
it's any good we serve actually amazing
the better
no sugar it's a great alternative for
actual peanut butter cups really good
addicting yeah you have to hide them in
the fridge go ahead and try this and
make put your comments below or no yeah
testing 1 ft 1 2 3 4 you got it that's
good
would you be serious we're trying to
create video this is serious business
here you have to stage the jokes with
the script amount and have them exactly
in the script
all right so let's let's get started
okay okay ready
what do I do with my hands yeah okay
come on come on oh okay let me I'm gonna
start it yeah
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk with you I'm waiting hey guys thank
you so much for watching please click
the subscribe button and I will see you
in the next video